السيدات والساده
ونحن نعقد هذه القمه في عالم مضطرب فان
الامل يرتفع في ظل التقارب العربي العربي
والعربي الاقليمي والدولي والذي توج بهذه
القمه والتي اتمنى ان تشكل بدايه مرحله
جديده للعمل العربي للتضامن فيما بيننا
للسلام في منطقتنا للتنميه والازدهار بدلا
من الحرب والدمار والتزاما بالدقائق الخمس
المخصصه للكلمات اتوجه بالشكر العميق
لرؤساء الوفود الذين عبروا عن الموده
المتاصله تجاه سوريا وابادلهم بالمثل كما
اذكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين على الدور
الكبير الذي قام به وجهود المكثفه التي
بدلها لتعزيز المصالحه في منطقه
هذه القمه واتمنى له والاسم ولي العهد
وللشعب السعودي الشقيق دوام التقدم
والازدهار
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات